the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what sob ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
8 Theory video hopefully by this time
all of you had the chance to watch the
brand new teaser HBO uploaded to promote
their final season a game of Thrones in
the new teaser we can see Jon Snow Arya
Stark and Sansa Stark down in the crypts
below Winterfell and after this came out
I did make a video where I gave my
initial thoughts on the new teaser what
I want to do today is dive a little
deeper into the mysterious crypts of
Winterfell since HBO did dedicate an
entire teaser to this specific location
under Winterfell I have a very good
feeling it has some sort of connection
to the end game of the series this is
something I had said in a few of my
previous videos before thanks to the new
teaser I thought that since the crypts
Winterfell were refreshing everyone's
minds this would be a good time to talk
about some of the other theories
surrounding the mysterious section of
the Starks Castle now when it comes to
the Starks underground cemetery this is
a place that has always been shrouded in
mystery but some of their deepest and
darkest secrets could come to light by
the end of the final season so everyone
go and make sure you grab yourself a
candle because I want to head down into
the crypts of Winterfell where we last
saw Jon Sansa and Arya as they were
getting ready to defend themselves from
an attack by the night king for those of
you that don't know one of my favorite
aspects of A Song of Ice and Fire and
Game of Thrones mostly involves things
that are taking place in the north there
is something about the history of House
Stark and the White Walkers that has
always fascinated me the most as I have
said time and time again I believe the
Starks and the knight King have a
connection to each other that dates all
the way back to the Age of Heroes this
is when the White Walkers were first
created and House Stark was founded I
also tend to believe that the crypts of
Winterfell which lie below the castle
are another piece of the puzzle that
helped connect the night King and House
Stark like I said at the beginning of
the video I did mention some of this
stuff in my teaser breakdown video but
now I want to take the time to go into
the details a little bit more
at the very beginning a Game of Thrones
Season eight we will get an opening
scene at Winterfell with the arrival of
Jon Snow and Daenerys Targaryen this
will be the first time all of the stark
children are in the same location since
the very first season of the show I'm
assuming that most of us are excited to
see all the Starks together again but
what makes it even more interesting is
the fact that Daenerys Targaryen dragons
will be in Winterfell as well one thing
we have learned is that the dragons
actually intensify the magic throughout
Westeros there is even a quote that says
when the last dragon died the magic and
Westeros started to fade away as well
now that the dragons are back the magic
has started to come back as well and
when the dragons are in the north their
presence alone could awaken something
within the crypts of Winterfell like I
said earlier the crypts of Winterfell
has always been shrouded in mystery we
still don't know who or what is down
there in the lowest levels but whatever
it is could awaken or be found very very
soon we do know that the members of
House Stark who grew up in Winterfell
has some sort of mystical or magical
connection to their crypts below the
castle if you have read the books you
would also know that the author has left
these breadcrumbs throughout each book
that continue to tell us how special of
a place this is for House Stark I don't
think it's just because this is where
they keep their loved ones after they
pass I believe there is a much bigger
seeker down there just waiting to get
revealed this could happen in one of the
last books but I am curious about
whether or not this will get revealed in
the final season of the television show
now that HBO has released a new teaser
based solely on the crypts of Winterfell
I think the chances of that happening
just dramatically increased another one
of the biggest mysteries of A Song of
Ice and Fire was the true identity of
Jon Snow's mother this is something that
was set up all the way back in the very
first season what has made this even
more interesting is the fact that Jon's
mother has been hiding right under his
nose the entire time because she has
been kept down in the crypts of
Winterfell ever since she died after
giving birth to Jon this creates a
connection between Jon Snow's parents
and the crypts of Winterfell we get
clues about both mysteries during some
of Jon Snow's dreams and one of these
dreams Jon was wandering the empty
Castle searching for his father
descending into the crypts only this
time the dream had gone further than
before in the dark he'd heard the scrape
of stone on stone
he turned he saw that the vaults were
opening one after the other as the dead
Kings came stumbling from their cold
black graves I find this dream to be
fascinating because it gives us clues
about several different things the first
thing it does is show the connection
between the crypts of Winterfell and Jon
Snow's parents as I said before Jon
cannot find his father down there
because John's actual father is not a
member from al stark as we all know
John's father is Rhaegar Targaryen now
what's interesting about this dream is
it says John had gone further than
before
this means that John is searching in
some of those lower levels where I
believe something is hiding we're most
likely one of the Starks deepest and
darkest secrets is kept there has to be
a reason why we learn about the
different levels below Winterfell
because I believe we will eventually see
a character go down there and find
something maybe they wish they hadn't
when I made my teaser breakdown video
just a few nights ago I told you there
were some hints in the books about the
kings of winter rising from the dead one
of those clues is in this dream that Jon
is having right here as you can see it
says when he turned he saw that the
vaults were opening one after the other
as the dead Kings came stumbling from
their code black graves in the new
teaser when we see Jon sons and arya
standing near their own statues we begin
to see the cold air or mist entering the
crypts my first initial thought was this
is the night king coming to get them but
I also thought that it could be those
kings of winter coming back alive what
if those dead Kings do come stumbling
from their cold black graves what if
this cold air or mist is actually coming
out of their statues as they begin to
awaken Jon has another very interesting
dream where we get some more clues this
time Jon dreams that he was back in
Winterfell limping past the stone King's
on their Thrones their gray granite eyes
turned to follow him as he passed and
their gray granite fingers tightened on
the health of the rusted swords upon
their laps
you are no Stark he could hear them
mutter and heavy granite voices there is
no place for you here
go away he walked deeper into the
darkness all right now let's break this
down once again we get another clue
about Jon's parents when Jon goes down
here he can hear them saying that he's
not a stark they say there is no place
for you here go away we later come to
find out why they would be
saying something like this to John at
first we might think it's because he's a
bastard and bastards do not get put down
into the crypts of Winterfell however
this is not the only reason why John
would not have a place down there that's
because John is a Targaryen a legitimate
Targaryen who is next in line for the
Iron Throne
another thing that John does in the
dream is he continues to go deeper into
the darkness down into those lower
levels I talked about before something
is down there that is calling out the
John to come and find out whatever it is
we also get more references to those
kings of winter coming alive again in
this dream their eyes are following John
as he walks past them their fingers are
also getting tighter around the hilts of
their swords they are even speaking out
to John by telling him that he doesn't
belong down there it's almost as if
they're getting angry at John for even
visiting their final resting place it
almost sounds like they want to fight
because they are beginning to grab their
swords from their laps one other thing
that I noticed is it also appears as if
John has some sort of injury during that
dream it says that John is walking with
a limp he is limping past the stone
kings on their Thrones this makes me
wonder if John will suffer some sort of
injury during the big battle which in
turn causes him to run down into the
crypts of Winterfell for some reason
maybe he goes down there to hide or find
some special weapon or perhaps something
that has to do with these dead Kings
waking up like I said there has to be
some sort of significance to HBO release
in a teaser that featured John down here
in the crypts of Winterfell what
intrigued me the most about that teaser
is how it gave us a clue about the
connection between the night King and
the crypts of Winterfell there has to be
a really good reason why they would show
the night Kings cold air creeping into
that location I know that whenever I
think about the night king two things
always come to my mind what does the
night King symbolize well one thing you
could say he symbolizes his death but
another thing I directly relate to him
is winter he comes from the lands of
always winter after all and he also
brings the winter storm wherever he goes
we can even see that winter air coming
into the crypts of Winterfell the oldest
statues that are kept down there are
known as the kings of winter but you
could also say that the night king is a
king of winter in fact I would say he is
the
king of winter when I made my teaser
breakdown video I talked about what
could possibly be kept down there below
Winterfell I briefly talked about how
the original night's queen or nights
king could be locked up down there in
the lowest levels well what I want to do
now is go into some more of the details
about why I think that is possible let's
get into some of the actual evidence
from the text in order for me to do so
we need to go all the way back to the
Age of Heroes this is around the time
that the White Walkers were created but
this is also when Winterfell was built
and how stark was founded now according
to the legend Winterfell was built by
Brandon the Builder who was aided by
giants after the long night and did
8,000 years ago
let's dissect that small piece of
information right there so as we all
know the long night started when the
White Walkers came for the first time we
learn about this during one of old Nan's
bedtime stories theaters for the long
night when the Sun hides for years and
children are born and live and die all
in darkness that is the time for fear my
little Lord when the White Walkers move
through the woods things get so bad that
it actually appears as if the White
Walkers are going to completely overrun
Westeros this is when we hear the legend
about someone known as the last hero
with the help of the children of the
forest the last hero is able to somehow
stop the White Walkers from advancing
any further south this leads to the
White Walkers running back into the
north and after the White Walkers
returned to the lanes of always winter
this is when Brandon the Builder raises
the wall with the help of the Giants and
the children of the forest after Brandon
the Builder raises the wall to keep the
White Walkers out of Westeros he then
constructs a second line of defense this
is when he builds Winterfell but before
he raises the castle he first builds the
crypts of Winterfell now think about
what that legend actually tells us after
the generation long winter known as the
long night comes to an end
Brandon builds another stronghold for
his descendants he doesn't just build
them a place to live it says he builds
them a stronghold which is basically a
fortress this is in case the White
Walkers ever come back and are able to
get past the wall if they're able to do
that then the Starks would need another
low
in the north to help them defend
Westeros this is why Winterfell was
built but since he built the crypts of
Winterfell first right after the long
night ended who could he have possibly
put down they're underground at that
time who are these original kings of
winter well let's take a look at a few
quotes that describe these old statues
under Winterfell the crypts beneath
Winterfell are located below Winterfell
and they contained the tombs of the
members of House Stark the cavernous
vault is larger than winter fo itself
with older Starks buried in deeper and
darker levels the lowest level is said
to be partly collapsed and the statues
have large stone direwolves curled at
their feet according to tradition iron
long swords lay across each Lord's lap
to keep the vengeful spirits within the
crypts now take a look at that very last
sentence describing what they do to the
statues ever since the very first king
of winter was put below Winterfell they
have added large stone direwolves curled
at their feet and they place iron
longswords across their labs to keep the
vengeful spirits within the crypts this
tradition could have started to help
keep the first night king or white
Walker as a prisoner down there I find
it very interesting that the Starks have
been attempting to keep the vengeful
spirits locked up in there crypts by
using iron long swords placed across
their laps you know what else has made
out of iron down here in the crypts the
crypts iron wood door which is located
in the oldest section of Winterfell near
the first keep it sounds like that iron
wood door has been there ever since the
crypts were built into the ground that's
why the door is located in the oldest
section of Winterfell near the first
keep so now we know they use our long
swords to keep the spirits within their
statues but if they ever get out of
their statues they have added a second
layer of protection by making the door
out of iron wood now I know what some of
you may be thinking what does iron have
to do with keeping the night King or the
White Walkers locked away have we ever
been told that the White Walkers do not
like iron well yes yes we have old nan
also told us that they hated iron let's
take a look at the quote old nan nodded
in that darkness the others came for the
first time she said as their needles
went click-click-click they were
cold things dead things that hated iron
and fire in the touch of the Sun in
every creature with hot blood in its
veins when John Snow is at the wall he
tells the exact same story old man told
the brand he even mentions how the White
Walkers hate iron now I know it can't be
the only one who finds that to be very
interesting Winterfell
along with the crypts of Winterfell were
built right after the long night ended
at a time in which the White Walkers
were very active when old nan tells the
story about the long night and the
others coming for the first time she
says they only hate a few things at that
time they hated fire the Sun and iron
now could it really be a coincidence
that the Starks are using iron long
swords and iron door and their crypts to
keep those spirits locked up I think
they are doing that because they are
scared of what would happen if they ever
got out we do know that the Starks keep
their loved ones down there but when the
castle was originally built I believe
they were keeping some other things down
there as well I think that the crypts of
Winterfell were originally built to be a
prison for the dead why do you think Jon
Snow's dreams of the Dead Kings
stumbling out of their statues are so
terrifying that's because of who these
dead kings of winter actually are now if
you remember in my teaser breakdown
video then you should remember a quote
that I referenced about the kings of
winter in the very first book a game of
Thrones Ned Stark has a dream where he
is walking through the crypts of
Winterfell
and we get two very important clues
during that dream during Ned's dream it
says he was walking through the crypts
beneath Winterfell as he had walked a
thousand times before the kings of
winter watched him pass with eyes of ice
when it says the kings of winter are
watching Ned as he walks past them this
is another reference to them actually
coming alive but as I said in my last
video the description of their eyes
really stand out to me now let's take a
look at another quote that describes
what the White Walkers eyes actually
look like because it sounds exactly like
what Ned sees during that dream we get
this description at the very beginning
of the story when the White Walkers are
first introduced in the prologue or the
pilot episode we'll saw its eyes blue
deeper and bluer than any humans eyes a
blue
that burned like ice so now we know the
kings of winter have eyes of ice just
like the White Walkers this makes me
wonder who or what is actually inside of
those statues why are all the dreams of
the crypts of Winterfell so damn ominous
or foreboding we have heard the White
Walkers have eyes of ice and we have
heard that the statues have eyes of ice
but do we know of any Starks that had
eyes of ice now let me show you another
quote that I think creates a connection
between the two in a Davos chapter we do
learn about a Stark who was a king
during a very long winter this start
doesn't sound anything like the Starks
that we know today in fact I don't think
you would ever want to meet this stark
make sure you pay very close attention
to each word that is used in the
paragraph a long cruel winter fell the
white knife froze hard and even the
Firth was icing up the winds came
howling from the north and drove them
slavers inside to huddle round their
fires and while they warmed themselves
the new king come down on them Brandon
Stark this was a Jurek's no beards
great-grandson him that men called ice
ice he took the Wolf's den back
stripped the slavers naked and he gave
them to the slaves that he found chained
up in the dungeons it said they hung
their entrails in the branches of the
Hart tree as an offering to the gods the
old gods not these new ones from the
south you're seven don't know winter in
winter don't know them now I don't know
about you but that doesn't sound like
your typical stark it says this stark
was named Brandon Stark but the men
called him
ice ice it also sounds like he rode down
on the winds of winter during a long
winter that fell it also said he was a
new king it doesn't say he was king in
the north or even a king of winter it
just says new king so maybe just maybe
he was the new night king riding down on
the winds of winter to take the wolf
stand back and have those slavers
entrails hung up in the weirwood tree as
an offering to the old gods the Starks
that we know don't do [ __ ] like this
unless this particular stark known as
ice sighs just so happened to cross over
to the other side and by the other side
I am of course referring to the white
Walker's side so perhaps these are the
eyes of ice that Ned dreams about when
he's walking around in the crypts of
Winterfell and when we see that cold air
creeping into the crypts in the new
teaser maybe this is the man that could
come stumbling out of one of those
statues that John always dreamed about
let's continue another thing that I find
very interesting is this isn't the only
Brandon Stark
who would have had eyes of ice Oh nan
tells us a second story about another
character known as Brandon Stark but
this time we know that he ends up
working for the side of the White
Walkers and there is a very good chance
that he was locked up in the crypts of
Winterfell after he was slain the reason
I believe the night's king was brought
back to Winterfell is because he was
killed by his own brother who just so
happened to be the stark of Winterfell
at that time as we all know the Starks
do not burn their ancestors they take
them down into the crypts of Winterfell
therefore the night's king should still
be down there let's take a look at old
man's story just in case some of you
haven't read it before old nan said he
had been the 13th man to lead the Nights
Watch a woman was his downfall
a woman glimpsed from atop the wall with
skin as white as the moon and eyes like
blue stars fearing nothing he chased her
and caught her and loved her though her
skin was cold as ice and when he gave
his seed to her he gave his soul as well
all right so let's break this part of
the story down first as you can see this
story takes place roughly 8,000 years
ago this was shortly after the wall was
constructed after all this Brandon Stark
was only the 13th Lord Commander of the
Nights Watch so this isn't too long
after the Nights Watch was created if
you remember right before Jon Snow
joined the Nights Watch Ned Stark told
him that the wall had been manned by
Starks for thousands of years that's
great honor serving in the Nights Watch
the stalks of mine the wool for
thousands of years I happen to think
that this is for the same reason why a
stark must always remain in Winterfell
you see when I fell and the wall was
built by a stark known as Brandon the
Builder as I said before these two
structures were built to help defend
against an attack by the White Walkers
since Brandon the Builder made
Winterfell in the wall
I believe he left his own family members
in charge of guarding them now we
obviously know a stark was left in
Winterfell because that is where their
house was founded but I also believe the
very first Lord Commander of the Nights
Watch was a stark as well there always
needs to be a stark at the wall just
like there always needs to be a stark
and Winterfell this is another reason
why House Stark has always had a close
connection to the White Walkers
but once Brandon stark became the 13th
Lord Commander of the Nights Watch
things started to change this is when
the White Walkers attempted to seduce
Brandon Stark by sending a female white
Walker that was unresisted this is kind
of similar to what happened to Jon Snow
Jon was never supposed to fall in love
with the woman that lived on the other
side of the wall but he couldn't help
himself
just like the 13th floor commander only
this time things would play out a little
differently he brought the female white
Walker back to the night for and he
proclaimed her acquaintance himself her
king and was some kind of sorceries he
was able to bound his sworn brothers to
as well for 13 years they had ruled
nights King and his corpse Queen till
finally the stark of Winterfell
enjoyment of the wildlings had joined to
free the watch from bondage after his
fall when it was found that he had been
sacrificing to the others
all records of the Nights King had been
destroyed his very name forbidden but
old nan said he was a stark the brother
of the man who brought him down he was a
stark of Winterfell and who can say
mayhaps his name was Brandon mayhaps he
slept in this very bed in this very room
so as you can see this is another
reference to a person named Brandon
Stark who would have had eyes of ice
this story tells us that the night's
King was killed by his own brother who
was a stark of Winterfell at the time
now what do you think he would have done
with his brother's body like I said the
stark stone burned their family members
we know where they put their loved one
even if they are thought to be evil this
is why the Starks begun the tradition of
placing iron longswords across the laps
of the statues that way the spirits do
not get out
Onan told us that the White Walkers
hated iron so as long as the iron is
still there then the spirits should not
be able to get out however there is one
problem these iron swords have been
rusting away for quite some time let's
take a look at one more quote this quote
could explain what is happening in that
teaser when we see the cold air coming
into the crypts of Winterfell now I know
that it certainly could mean that the
night King is getting very close to
Winterfell but it could also mean that
something is waking up down in the
crypts this is what was said in one of
the very first chapters of the books and
it looks like it could possibly come
true in one of the last chapters of the
story
by ancient custom and iron longsword had
been laid across the lap of each who had
been Lord of Winterfell to keep the
vengeful spirits in their crypts the
oldest had long ago rusted away to
nothing
leaving only a few red stains where the
metal had rested on stone
Ned wondered if that meant those ghosts
were free to roam the castle now he
hoped not
you
[Music]
[Music]